Church in one of Southern California's
wealthiest communities says it has
stopped serving dinners to the homeless
under pressure from the city the United
Methodist Church in Malibu recently
canceled its weekly meal program
organizers say officials in the seaside
community voiced concerns after
receiving public safety complaints Jamie
yuccas is at the church in Malibu Jamie
good morning good morning the homeless
meals are served at this church campus
but you can feed on the sign it's also
home to a nursery school directly behind
the church is a middle school and high
school city officials are concerned that
dozens of homeless people come here many
from outside communities Malibu
California is known worldwide for its
secluded beaches sun-drenched streets
and multi-million dollar homes but
living among Malibu's well-to-do are the
down-and-out for years volunteers at the
city's United Methodist Church have
pulled out food carts and set tables
serving as many as a hundred meals each
week to the homeless like Micah Johnson
they keep me accountable and the church
is really helpful keeping my spirits up
Reggie Coco's organization ran the
program until earlier this month he says
the city asked him to stop they were
trying to highly encourage us to use the
resources that they already have
Malibu's mayor says the city never
forced the program to end but he does
have serious concerns that homeless from
around LA County are taking the bus to
Malibu for the free meals
mayor skyler pete and what comes with
that would some of those people is drug
use is assault the Los Angeles Sheriff's
Department says homeless related service
calls including those reporting crimes
have more than tripled in the Malibu
area from 2011 to 2016 truth be told
I've never met any of these people that
are causing these problems it sounds
like you just don't want these people
here let's just move to the next town no
no we're doing a better job of getting
them resources and we're going to
continue to do that we're going to
continue to get better at it
city officials say they already work
with two full-time outreach workers that
connect the homeless with programs
including health services shelter and
substance abuse counseling but they
aren't currently handing out meals and
goko says his dinners provide a vital
connection that the city can't duplicate
to us it's more than just the dinners
it's not food it's not really the
relation it's the relationship it's the
mentorship that's that's where you get
people lit up from within and they
actually go out on their own
the city says one possible solution is
handing out box lunches around town in
other locations city leaders and
community leaders will meet once again
on Monday to discuss this meal program
flat Jamie yuccas thank you very much